russian forces are expected to set up
their offensive after claiming to have
taken control of ukraine's easternmost
province holly williams is in southern
ukraine with the latest on the fighting
there holly good morning
good morning the loss of the city of
lissa chunsk to russia is a big blow to
the ukrainians and gives russia yet
another foothold to grab more territory
in the east which is the focus of
moscow's invasion after weeks of intense
fighting ukraine's military said its
forces withdrew from lester chance
because continuing to defend their
positions would have had quote fatal
consequences now ukraine has put up a
surprisingly effective defense during
this war aided by nearly seven billion
dollars in u.s military assistance since
the invasion began as well as some major
failings on the part of russian forces
but make no mistake the russians are
seizing towns and cities and next in
russia's firing line could be the city
of slavyansk where there's been heavy
shelling in a new video message released
overnight ukraine's president vladimir
zelinski vowed that his military would
return to lysichansk we will rebuild the
walls we will win back the land he said
ukraine does not give anything up ed
holly williams in ukraine thank you so
much